[Music]
new at four o'clock if you're looking
for a new home you might be in luck
according to Las Vegas Realtors we're in
what they call a balanced Market which
can be good news for both the buyer and
the seller eight news now's Brian will
breaks down what that means for you
what do you guys think the buyers
actually in a better position now
because prices have stabilized in some
cases gone down more Lee Barrett has
been in the real estate business for
over 40 years he's seen a lot and says
the housing market is starting to
correct itself it's what we call a
balanced Market it doesn't favor the
seller doesn't favor the buyer it's
actually a really good market for all
people because it doesn't favor you the
party while the market is balanced right
now that doesn't mean you should be
taking your time putting in that offer
or if you're the seller waiting for the
best price the market may be cooling off
but it's not slowing down I believe
we're not going to see another dip
because we're going into the spring
market and that will go ahead and give
us a increase of buyers coming into the
marketplace when compared to last year
home prices are down two percent the
amount of houses on the market are up
almost 200 percent and the amount of
days houses are staying on the market is
almost 90 days compared to less than 60
in 2022 but the tough news for buyers is
the average interest rate according to
bank rate is 6.8 percent versus three
percent last year because the one
variable is always interest rates so if
you got a lower price and you had to pay
a little bit higher interest rate and
interest rates go when they go back down
you can take the opportunity to be
refinance your home and get that lower
interest rate as for sellers your best
advice is to sell when it's right for
you the sellers are more in a position
to be favorable to 2-1 buy downs and
other things that would help the buyer
get into the property
and keep in mind during January Las
Vegas Realtors found more than 27
percent of all the local property sales
were purchased with cash that's down
from 30 percent a year ago but well
below the March 2013 cash buyer Peak
that was nearly 60 percent of buyers
were paying cash